Mechanisms of evolution.
What is evolution?
Evolution is the development of life on earth.
This is a process that began billions of years ago and is still continuing to
this day.
Evolution tells us how it was possible for the enormous diversity of life to
develop.
It shows us how primitive protozoa could become the millions of different
species that we see today.
Evolution then is the answer to the question that we have all asked on seeing a
Dachsund and a great Dane together.
How it possible for ancestors to have to sentence that look so very different to
them
and answering this question,
we want to focus on animals excluding other forms of life such as Funghi
implants.
The first question to ask cause therefore,
how can one animal developed into a whole new species of animal?
But just a quick question.
What exactly [inaudible] is a species.
A species is a community of anime.
What was that is capable of producing offspring with one another with those
offspring also being capable of reproducing.
In turn to understand this answer better,
we need to take a closer look at the following points.
The uniqueness of living creatures guaranteed through the excess production of
offspring and heredity.
And as a second key point selection,
let's begin with uniqueness.
Every creature that exists as unique and this is essential for evolution,
the members of a species may strongly resemble each other in appearance.
However,
they all have slightly different traits and characteristics.
They may be a bit bigger,
fatter,
stronger,
or bolder than their fellow animals.
So what is the reason for these differences?
Let's take a closer look at a creature.
Every creature is made up of cells.
The cells have a nucleus,
the nucleus contains the chromosomes,
and the chromosomes hold.
The DNA.
DNA consists of different genes and it's these genes that are life's information
carriers.
They contain instructions and orders for the cells and determine the
characteristics and traits that living creatures have.
Yeah,
and it's precisely this DNA that is unique to every creature.
It's slightly different from individual to individual,
which is why each has slightly different characteristics.
But how is the enormous range of DNA create it?
Okay.
One key factor is the excess production of offspring in nature.
We can observe that creatures generally produce far more offspring than is
necessary for the survival of their species with many offspring dying an early
death.
As a result,
often there are even more offspring than the environment in which they live is
able to support.
This is one factor in increasing diversity within a species.
The more offspring that are produced,
the mall,
little differences occur,
and this is what nature wants as many little differences as possible.
The second major cause of the uniqueness of individuals occurs in heredity
itself.
By the way,
heredity means the passing on of DNA to offspring
to very interesting factors come into play in this process.
Recombination and mutation
recombination is the random mixing of the DNA of two creatures.
When two creatures fall in love and mate,
they recombine their jeans twice
the first time.
They do this separately.
When they generate the gamuts that his sperm and egg cells,
the gamuts take half of the genes and shuffled them.
The secondary combination occurs when email in seven eight so female.
The parents each provide 50% of their DNA.
In other words,
50% of their unique traits and characteristics.
These are then recombined or mixed and the result is new offspring.
These offspring have a random mix of the DNA and therefore the traits and
characteristics of their parents.
This increases the diversity and differences within a species even further,
but two mutations are also important for evolution.
Mutations are random changes in DNA.
These can also be described as copying errors within the DNA triggered by toxins
or other chemical substances all by radiation.
A mutation exists when a part of the DNA is altered.
These changes are often negative and may result in illnesses such as cancer.
However,
they may also have a neutral or positive effects such as the blue eye color in
humans,
which is one such random mutation.
In all cases,
a mutation has to affect a gamut that is a spur more XL because only the DNA in
the gamuts is passed onto the offspring.
This is also the reason why we protect our sexual organs during x-rays,
whilst other parts of the body are not at risk.
In summary then in the heredity process,
creatures pass on their characteristics to their offspring in the form of DNA
recombination and mutation change the DNA,
so each child looks different too.
It's siblings and receives a random mix of the characteristics of its parents.
There's a key word here,
random.
All of these processes are based on chance,
random recombination and mutations result in individuals with random mixes of
traits and characteristics,
which in turn mixed these randomly and pass them on.
But how can so much be down to chance when all living creatures are so perfectly
adapted to their environment.
For example,
the stick insect,
the Hummingbird,
and the frog fish,
the answer is provided by the second key point selection.
Each individual is subjected to a process of natural selection.
As we have learned,
each individual is somewhat different to its fellows and there is extensive
variation within a species.
Environmental influences have an effect on living creatures.
The so called selection factors include predators,
parasites,
animals of the same species,
toxins,
changes in habitat.
All the climate selection is a process that each individual is subjected to.
Every creature has a unique mix of traits and characteristics.
This makes,
helps them to survive in their environment or not.
As the case may be,
anyone with an unsuitable mix will be selected from the environment.
Those were the right mix.
Survive and can pass on their enhanced traits and characteristics.
Yeah.
This is why diversity is so important.
This is why creatures make so much effort to produce offspring that are as
different as possible.
They increase the likelihood that at least one of their offspring passes nature
selection process.
They maximize their chances of survival.
A good example of this can be seen in a group of finches living on a remote
island.
They are some of the most famous animals in the world of science and are known
as Darwin finches after that discover Charles Darwin,
and this is the story of those finches.
A few hundred years ago,
a small group of finches was blown onto the Galapagos islands in the middle of
the Pacific,
probably by a big storm,
the finch finches found themselves in an environment that was completely new to
them,
a real finch paradise and abundance of food and no predators.
They reproduced rapidly and numerously.
The islands were soon heaving with finches.
This meant that food supplies became increasingly scarce.
The finch paradise was threatened with famine and finch friends became,
this is when selection intervened.
Their individuality and small differences.
In this case,
they're slightly different.
Beaks med,
the some of the birds were able to avoid competing with their fellow finches.
The beaks of some of the finches were more suitable for digging for worms.
Other finches,
we're able to use their beaks better for cracking seat.
Okay.
The finches consequently salt out ecological niches and these niches,
they were safe from excessive competition.
They sit and began to meet primarily with other finches that use the same niche
over the course of many generations.
These characteristics were enhanced enabling the finches to exploit their Nisha
successfully.
The differences between the worm diggers and the seed crackers became so large
that they were no longer able to meet with one another.
Different species emerged as a result.
Today there are 14 different species of finch living on the Galapagos islands,
all of which are descended from the same group of stranded finches.
This is how new species are created by evolution through the interaction of
unique individuals,
the excess production of offspring,
recombination and mutation in heredity,
and finally through selection.
Why is this so important?
It tells us whether the variety of life comes from and wine living creatures are
so perfectly adapted to that habitat,
but it also affects us personally.
Every person is the result of three and a half billion years of evolution and
that includes you.
Your ancestors fought and adapted in order to survive.
This survival was an extremely uncertain thing.
If we consider the fact that 99% of all the species that have ever lived are
extinct,
then you can consider yourself part of a success story.
The dinosaurs have disappeared,
but you are alive watching this video because you're incredibly special.
Just like all the other creatures that exist today,
irreproducible and unique in the universe.